hey guys in this video we're going to
talk about how to fix hypoglycemia
alright now what is hypoglycemia
hypoglycemia is a situation where the
blood sugars go to low now normally in
the body
you should have blood sugars of 100 what
does that mean that I'll give you a
little comparison if you were to weigh
let's say one hundred and eighty pounds
and you'd have about a gallon and a half
of blood in your entire body the amount
of sugar that would be diluted in there
to equal 100 would be about one teaspoon
so it's really very small amounts of
sugar and it doesn't mean you have to
eat sugar your body can make sugar from
other types of things like protein even
fat so it's not that you have to even
eat any sugar at all but the point is we
need this normal blood sugar to maintain
fuel in the body okay it should be 100
when it drops down below 70 that's when
you start getting the symptoms of
hypoglycemia brain fog cravings for
sweets anxiety fatigue shaking this
Weeki weakness it's kind of like if you
have kids you know and you let's say
you're bringing them grocery shopping
with you when they're hungry and tired
they're going to experience all these
specifically irritability right and
that's a low blood sugar and you're just
going to kind of go a little crazy on
you so the point is that when those
blood Sugar's crash it pushes you out of
the present you don't think rationally
and you'll eat things that you end up
regretting so here's what happens and
this is the problem is that the doctors
the medical profession is telling people
to keep some candy in their pocket or
glucose tablets in case your blood
sugars run low go ahead and take some
candy and bring them back up right and
these are even diabetics so they're
looking at this problem very
superficially you know it's like it's
kinda like if you stub your toe and well
just here just take a pain pill every
time you step your toe but like why
don't we just look at why you're
stepping your cell in the same spot so
the why is this if you're taking
medication and it's spiking it of
insulin too high and your blood sugars
are coming down too fast it could be
that you're taking too much medication
okay so using the lesson of medication
rather than try to correct it at the
blood sugar level to add more sugar into
the mix which will create more problem
why not just take a little less next
time to even it out that's one solution
next solution is to get out of the diet
what triggers this in the first place
and I have a ton of videos on that I'll
put them down below you know the sugar
is refined carbohydrates and things like
that but I'm going to tell you an
equally important thing and it has to do
with the opposing hormone to insulin
okay insulin reacts to glucose and what
it does is it lowers blood sugar and so
there's a hormone that does the opposite
and it's made by the pancreas so insulin
is made by the pancreas but this hormone
is also made by the pancreas too and
this is the missing piece and I'm going
to explain why it's called glucagon
glucagon okay so that kind of does the
opposite of insulin so if insulin lowers
blood sugars glucagon raises blood
sugars okay so what it does it is it
mobilizes and releases stored sugar from
your liver and even the muscles so you
have this thing called glycogen that's
torture glucagon releases that to keep
the sugars constant so you have this
constant thing where your insulin and
glucagon are working together alright
so now here's the question why don't we
just increase glue gun instead of eating
candy why don't we do that well because
we will not really understand what what
triggers will be on so I'm teaching you
right now the main food that will
trigger glucagon is ready for this
protein moderate amount of protein not a
lot just just you know moderate between
3 to maybe 5 ounces of protein protein
will trigger glucagon and I have a
little story I I would have blood sugar
issues when I was very
and then one day for breakfast I would
normally have like a carbohydrate
breakfast I decided to have some protein
it was like a switch I instantly like
could think again I was feeling so much
better mentally I was clearer it wasn't
all foggy like I used to be and that was
because of this situation right here so
it brought it up normally so the point
is if you're doing a very low protein
diet and you're not having protein with
each meal and on this thing have a lot
just a little bit especially in the
morning if you're going to have
breakfast so then you could be having
this hypoglycemic reaction so that's one
cause another one be reading too much
sugar the third one would be you're
basically eating your you're a diabetic
and you're taking medication that's too
much and you need to adjust that but
it's hypoglycemia is very very easy to
correct if you understand this right
here I put some links down below of the
eating plan for like insulin resistance
and things like that but the point I
want to make is instead of going for
that candy in your pocket protein would
be the thing you need to do to drive it
up and then as far as a meal goes to
really correct this even long term you
don't want to have snacks between the
meal now I know hypoglycemics need to
eat between the meals because their
blood Sugar's crashed well a much better
thing would be to do would be to add a
little fat with that meal so you have
like a good amount of vegetables protein
and fat healthy fats like avocado or
coconut oil or or even some animal fats
if here or or even butter but the point
is that you do that
that will not spike insulin it gives you
to go longer less spike drops and blood
sugars and if you do that consistently
you can actually heal this whole
mechanism and completely not be
hypoglycemic anymore it's also good for
hyperglycemic glycemia as well that's
diabetes so I wanted to mention this
point about protein so stop you having
the candy in the pocket down to the
glucose tablets I'm going to even have
like these little shakes you can do a
pure sugar you just you're never going
to fix your problem that way
so do the protein and put your comments
below thank you for watching